hi guys I won't take much of your time
so I just wanted to say oh hi it's a
lizard right here I'm not gonna bug him
not one of those people but we're up at
Keys point in Joshua Tree National Park
it's Amy's birthday was her birthday
yesterday so now if you could wish her a
happy birthday that'd be great in the
comments below
she's been getting a ton of fan art what
was it like seven days of keebz
seven days a piece I know so adore so
nice yeah so I just wanted to put out a
quick message there we're on the way
back pretty soon after we're done with
this so just a quick vlog today and then
videos back on schedule for tomorrow but
yeah we spent the weekend out here and
it's been really cool
I saw the stars really vividly at night
because there's very few light pollution
out here and this is really cool so this
is the last stop before I come home I'll
talk about more later but I promise not
to take up too much of your time and I
don't wanna be an out here
filming when everyone's enjoying the
view so thanks everybody for watching
what's your happy birthday for me please
I'll be good bye